All right.
So today's lecture is
a lecture about the
parts of the soul.
And I want to begin with some
passages, two from the ancient
Greek literary tradition, and
two from contemporary mass
culture, which bring out the
extent to which it is part of
the common understanding of
human nature that we are often
conflicted within ourselves.
So in The Republic, the book
from which we have been
reading excerpts, Plato's
Socrates tells a story about a
man who is tempted to act
against his better judgment.
And this is the story
of Leontius,
and it goes as follows.
"Leontius, the son of Aglaion,
was coming up from the Piraeus
along the outside of the north
wall of the city when he saw
some corpses lying at the
executioner's feet.
He had--
Socrates using Plato's
terminology of appetite--
"He had an appetite
to look at them.
But at the same time, he was
disgusted and turned away.
For a time," the story goes on,
"he struggled with himself
and covered his face.
But finally, overpowered by
appetite, he pushed his eyes
wide open and rushed towards the
corpses, saying, 'Look for
yourselves, you evil wretches!
Take your fill of the
beautiful sight.'"
Now, we'll talk more in today's
lecture about the
particular picture that Plato
has in mind when he speaks of
the tripartite soul as involving
this force that he
calls appetite.
But the basic description that
we have here doesn't rest in
any way on a particular
Platonic framework.
The idea that one can, on the
one hand, feel compelled to do
something--
eat a piece of chocolate cake,
check one's Facebook page--
those are temptations that one
can try to control, and
struggle with oneself about.
And the narrative that will take
place in the next four or
five lectures is about what
sorts of strategies are
available for us, given that
these kinds of conflicts
inevitably arise?
So that's our first example from
the ancient tradition of
a kind of conflict.
A conflict between a drive of
appetite, on the one hand, and
a drive of a certain kind of
self-regulation on the other.
Second example comes from
Ovid's Metamorphosis.
A long story in which, in the
passage that we're reading, a
character Medea has, against
her better judgment, found
herself in love with a young
man named Jason.
And here I'm using a
seventeenth century
translation that's actually
in rhyming couplets.
"Meanwhile Medea, seiz'd with
fierce desire,/ By reason
strives to quench the raging
fire;/ But strives in vain!
Some God (she said) withstands,/
and reason's
baffl'd counsel countermands."
So here's Medea, seized with
desire, trying to control
herself through reason, telling
herself: it's absurd
to be in love with this young
man, it's a violation of other
obligations that she has.
But she strived in vain.
She has the feeling of having
been overtaken by a force
outside herself, and what reason
is telling her to do is
overridden.
It continues--
this is a rhyming version of
the passage that's actually
quoted in prose form in the
Jonathan Haidt that we read
for today--continues--this
is now in Medea's voice.
"But love, resistless love, my
soul invades/ Discretion this,
affection that persuades./ I see
the right, and I approve
it too,/ Condemn the wrong--
and yet the wrong pursue."
So this feeling of seeing what
is right, endorsing what is
right, condemning what is wrong,
and yet nonetheless
finding oneself doing what
lies against one's better
judgment is a fundamental
trope in the
Western literary tradition.
It's a fundamental trope
in the Eastern
philosophical tradition.
And it's an extraordinarily
familiar feeling
in all of our lives.
Third example of the kind of
tension that is picked out by
this talk of parts of the soul
comes from today's Internet.
Here's a piece about last
year's Sweet Sixteen
bracketing decision.
And here's the headline.
"Emotions and analysis conflict
when picking Sweet
Sixteen winner.
Most of you, says this post,
involved in NCAA pools, had
difficult decisions last week
trying to decide whether your
hearts were trying to
lead you astray.
'It's difficult,'" he says,
echoing Medea, echoing Plato,
to remove emotion during (now in
his own words), "what many
consider to be the best
post-season in sports." And he
goes on to describe how
difficult it is to take
reason's mandate and select a
team to which you don't bear
emotional connections.
But we don't find this only in
the context of sportsmanship.
Here's a fourth example of the
sort of conflict of the soul
that Plato is talking about.
This one comes from the greatest
arbiter of mass
culture, Oprah.
"Listen up," says Oprah, on
Oprah's webpage, "Why Being in
your Heart is Better Than in
Your Head." So in this regard,
those of you who have done the
reading know that, if we had
clickers, she is agreeing
with Plato, or Hume?
Is she agreeing with Plato--
left hands--
Plato or Hume?
Excellent.
Good.
So Plato's idea is that
reason is in charge.
Hume's suggestion in the passage
that we read, he says,
reason is and ought to be the
slave of the passions.
Now, Hume isn't exactly saying
what Oprah is saying here.
That's something we'll
have a chance to talk
about more in sections.
But again, we see, just as we
saw in the story of Leontius,
the story of Medea, the story of
choosing your winning team
in basketball betting, and here
in Oprah, this idea that
the soul has parts, that there
are conflicts within us.
So what I want to do in today's
lecture is to talk
through with you the five
readings which I assigned for
today, three required, two
supplementary, each of which
attempts to give voice through
identification of a taxonomy
to this idea that we are
pulled sometimes in one
direction and sometimes
in another.
So the first, which I'll talk
about in detail later in the
lecture, is Plato's
division between
reason, spirit, and appetite.
The second is Hume's discussion
of the relation
between reason and passion.
And Jonathan Haidt, in the book
that we read the first
chapter of today, presents a
wonderful metaphor there, for
understanding the relation
between, on the one hand,
reason--the part of ourselves
to which we have direct,
conscious access, and over
which we have direct
regulative control--and the
other mass of drives and
instincts which compose us,
which he suggests we can
understand as an elephant
which we seek to control
through whatever mechanisms
are possible.
Hume's suggestion, in the
passage that we read, is that
the drive and the impetus
towards motion comes through,
to continue with the metaphor,
the creature whose feet are on
the ground.
So although it is the case
that there's a kind of
steering that's possible on
the part of the rider, the
impetus towards action comes
from those parts of us over
which we don't have direct
rational control.
And this idea that we are a
bundle of drives that pull us
in various directions lies at
the heart of the incredibly
influential, though highly
controversial, picture of the
human mind that Sigmund Freud
presented in the first half of
the century.
So Freud's idea is that each of
us, when we are born, are a
bundle of incoherent desires
and needs and passions.
We have a desire to eat, we
have a desire for certain
kinds of comfort, we
have incredibly
vivid sexual desires.
And those desires have
no degree of
consistency about them.
They pull us in every direction,
and they cause us
to act in ways that aim
at their satisfaction.
The story of human development,
says Freud, is
the story of going on to
develop two kinds of
regulative capacities.
The one, which he calls the
ego, is a part of the self
that is sensitive to reality.
It recognizes that you can't
simultaneously want to kill
your brother and marry your
brother, because if your
brother is dead, you
can't marry him.
It may recognize, in fact, that
you want neither to kill
your brother nor marry your
brother, though that bit of
information may come from
the third part.
So we have this bundle of
passions that pull us in
various directions.
And on top of that, as we
develop, comes a part of
ourselves which is sensitive
to reality.
And as that happens, we become
conscious of our experience.
So whereas these desires pull us
in various ways without our
even being aware of it, the
ego, the sense of self, is
something to which we have
reflective access.
As we go on to interact with
others in the world, we get
information about appropriate
ways in which to regulate
ourselves so as to conform with
the norms of society.
And as we internalize those,
and take them to be part of
what we ourselves endorse, they
become what Freud calls
the superego, sometimes thought
of as the conscience.
So the picture here is that
there are all sorts of
unconscious parts of ourselves,
some of which are
drives that pull us to do things
like eat and procreate,
some of which are aspects more
sensitive to the constraints
of reality, some of which are
the norms of society.
And then on top of that, in
a rather smaller part of
ourselves, is an aspect of
which we are conscious.
Now, there are details of the
Freudian picture which have
been discredited for all
sorts of reasons.
But the basic idea that we
have unconscious pulls in
directions which we disavow has
become, I think, part of
how it is that Western culture
self-conceives.
I think it's almost impossible
to underestimate the extent to
which the Freudian picture
underlies twentieth century
literature, twentieth century
film, and twentieth century
self-understanding.
Notice that the Freudian
picture, though it has three
parts, isn't exactly the
Platonic picture.
Appetite and id roughly
correspond, but spirit is not
the same thing as ego.
And reason and superego where
are only roughly correlated.
Those of you who are intrigued
by this discussion can go back
and look in this week's reading,
and read Freud's own
presentation of the theories
that I've described.
The fourth distinction which
I'll go on to discuss in the
main part of the lecture is a
contemporary extension between
system one and system two, or
between a sort of automatic
heuristic processing system
and a rational reflective
processing system.
And as I said, I'll talk
about that in the
bulk part of the lecture.
I want to just now introduce
our fifth set of divisions.
And these are the four divisions
which Jonathan Haidt
identifies in the
opening chapter.
So as you know, we read the
Plato, we had the option of
reading the Hume, the option of
reading the Freud, we read
the Evans piece and
we read the Haidt.
So Haidt's first distinction
is between what he
calls mind and body.
And what he points out there is
that so much of our bodily
regulation happens through the
brain, there are independent
loci of processing.
In particular, the gut, our
digestive organ, can run
relatively independently
of the brain.
And he provides some
examples of that.
But strikingly, one of the
things that he does not
discuss is the famous example of
Mike, the headless rooster,
who was a rooster--here he
is on the cover of Life
magazine--who soon after the
Second World War was beheaded,
and who went on to live
for another 18
months, perfectly happily.
Here he is again.
And if you go on YouTube, you
can actually watch a live
version of Mike the
headless chicken.
Those of you who have pledged to
turn off your Internet, are
regretting it now.
So the point about Mike the
headless chicken is that
there's a whole bunch of motor
control representations that
take place not in the organ
where one would typically
expect it, in the head, but
rather along the spinal cord
in various ways.
The first division to which
Haidt adverts is the fact that
it's actually a biological
feature of us.
That regulation of action
happens through all sorts of
biological processes, some of
which are located up here, and
others of which communicate with
the parts of our limbs
and so on, only through lower
parts of the spinal cord.
The second division that Haidt
reminds us of the importance
of is the division between left
brain and right brain.
As many of you know, we have
running along the middle of
our heads something called the
corpus callosum, which
connects all the stuff that
happens on the right side of
our head to all the stuff
that happens on the
left side of our head.
It turns out that in certain
kinds of epileptic patients,
the only way to cure their
epilepsy, their electric
seizures that run across the
brain, is by severing the
corpus callosum.
And by doing so, for medically
necessary purposes, science
has discovered the degree to
which the processing that goes
on in the two sides of the
brain is relatively
independent.
Basically, everything that comes
in through the right
visual field is processed in the
brain's left hemisphere,
and everything that comes in
through the left visual field
is processed in the brain's
right hemisphere.
And though many features of
the brain are duplicated
across the hemisphere, others
of them are localized.
In particular, in the brains
of right-handed people,
language is a right
[correction: left]
hemisphere activity.
And so Haidt describes some
famous research done in the
1950s by the neuroscientist
Michael Gazzaniga in which a
patient who had been subject
to a severing of the corpus
callosum, is presented with some
images that either come
in through the left visual field
and consequently are
processed on the right side of
the brain, or images that come
in from the right visual field,
and consequently are
processed on the left
side of the brain.
Interestingly, because
information processed on the
right side of the brain isn't
linguistically available--
I believe I misspoke earlier.
The language center is on the
left, not in the right brain--
isn't linguistically available,
when the subject
looks at something that comes
in over here, there's no
linguistic processing
of what he sees.
But when he's asked to explain
what it is that is in his
visual field, he engages in
what Gazzaniga called
confabulation.
So the gentleman here has been
shown with this side of the
brain a bunch of images
of snow, and
he is asked to choose--
remember, this is right brain,
so it's left hand--
something that goes with them.
And so he selects with his left
hand, controlled by the
right brain from the left
visual field, a shovel,
something which would
be enormously
useful if you had snow.
Meanwhile, the left side of his
brain through the right
eye, controlling the right hand,
sees a chicken claw and
selects a chicken.
So one side of his brain sees a
chicken claw, and selecting
the thing that goes with it,
selects the chicken.
The other side of his brain sees
the snow, and selecting
the thing that goes with
it, selects the shovel.
So far, so good.
I told you the brain is
segregated in these sorts of
ways, so it isn't surprising
that the right side is
selecting something that goes
with what it saw on the left
side, and selecting something
that goes with what it saw.
What happens next?
What happens next is that the
man looks down at the shovel
and the chicken, which he has
selected, and is confronted
with the question of why he
has chosen those things.
Now, as far as the language
center of his brain goes, he
has no idea why he's chosen
the chicken claw.
Right?
That information hasn't entered
into the part of his
brain where the linguistic
processes are taking place.
Nonetheless, what he does
is something called
confabulation.
He says, Oh.
I take the shovel because
I need to shovel
out the chicken coop.
He comes up with an explanation
for why it is that
he has chosen as
he has chosen.
And in cases of hypnosis,
there is a similar
phenomenology.
Subjects will find themselves
onstage with their arms ad
legs in a particular way, and
immediately come up with a
confabulated explanation for it
is why that they are doing
what they are doing.
We are quite typically people
who read our behavior off our
experience.
And when we talk about emotion
and self-understanding, we
will come back to this issue.
The point about left and right
brain is two-fold.
The first is that this is a
second example of a biological
underpinning of the
idea that we are
divided in certain ways.
And the second is the idea of
confabulation in the sense
that, to use the rider-elephant
metaphor, it's
as if the rider thinks that it's
his feet that are on the
ground rather than
the elephant's.
The third division which Haidt
describes to us is the
division between what he calls
old brain and new brain.
Roughly, the parts of our brain,
the brain stem and
subcortical regions, that we
share with nonhuman animals,
and the parts of our brain
that are much more highly
developed in human beings,
namely the cortical region and
the reticular, the prefrontal
cortex.
And Haidt tells there a story
which is useful for
understanding how it is that
self-regulation occurs.
So my guess is that many of you
have seen some version of
these famous images
of this person.
Anybody know the name
of this person?
Yeah.
Phineas Gage.
This is Phineas Gage, who was
a railroad worker in the
nineteenth century who was
tamping down some dynamite as
part of his job as a
railroad worker.
And the dynamite exploded, and
this long metal pole went
through his brain.
But, like Mike the headless
chicken, Phineas Gage was a
survivor, and in fact did not
die, but went to live for many
more years.
In reconstructing the accident,
it's become clear
that the damage which the pole
did was to an area of Gage's
brain called the ventromedial
prefrontal cortex.
Right up here is the
And the result of the accident
which happened to Gage was
like what happened to the
University of Virginia
schoolteacher that Haidt
describes in his story.
There was a lot of capacity
for a certain kind of
self-regulation.
So in some ways, like Medea,
though Gage was able to see
what the normatively correct
thing to do was--to see what
he ought to do, to understand
it, to explain it, to
articulate it, to say what was
appropriate--he found himself
unable to act on what it was
that he thought would be a
better idea.
So he would say something like,
you shouldn't yell and
scream when you're upset
in a public setting.
He would understand that that
sort of behavior was
inappropriate.
But he would nonetheless find
himself unable to act on that.
He would end up doing what Freud
would say his id told
him to do, or what Plato
would say his
appetite told him to do.
Again and again, it's been
discovered in subjects with
damage to the prefrontal
cortex that they face
difficulties with
self-regulation.
So it looks like at least one of
the places where what Plato
would call reason seats
itself is in this
particular part of the brain.
And, in fact, there is
reasonably good evidence that
individuals can suffer, for
example, from attention
hyperactivity deficit disorder,
ADHD, has lower
prefrontal cortex function
than those who do not.
So when Haidt speaks of old
brain--a part of the brain
that we share with beings who
act on instinct, and new
brain--cortex, and in
particular, the parts of the
cortex that are especially
well-developed in human
beings, like PFC--one of the
things that he is talking
about is this capacity
for self-regulation.
And when we talk about weakness
of the will in
roughly five classes, we'll talk
about some of the ways in
which we can exploit the fact
that we have these complex
brains capable of learning
patterns both though our old
system and through
our new one.
So we are capable of regulation
both in the way
that dogs and cats are.
If you want to train your cat
not to go on the couch,
saying, "Please don't go on the
couch, you'll leave fur
there, and my aunt is allergic,"
is in fact not an
effective way to train your cat
not to go on the couch.
To train your cat not to go on
the couch you need to do
something like put a crinkly
piece of paper there that
makes an ugly noise every
time she sits down.
Or perhaps spray her gently with
a water bottle whenever
she goes on the couch.
In so doing, you set up
associations between being on
the couch and a negative
outcome, and change her
associations with it.
But you don't do it in a way
that engages reflective
self-regulation.
We as human beings with both old
brain and new can regulate
ourselves in the way that we
regulate and train animals
through associating certain
activities with positive
things and other activities
with negative ones.
But we can also do so making
use of a kind of reflection
and self-regulation that
involves a certain kind of
self-control.
And we'll talk about that
more in later lectures.
So what I want to do now, having
given you first some
literary texts in which we have
articulated the idea of
the soul being divided, and then
quickly run through the
various divisions that we read
about today, is to--
Oh, sorry!
There's a fourth example
from Jonathan Haidt.
What I want to do, really, is
to tell you about controlled
and automatic processing,
and then do what I said
I would just do.
So some of you, at the
conclusion of this class, are
going to walk from this room,
perhaps by taking an elevator,
over to a lecture in another
part of WLH that is taught by
John Bargh.
And what I want to describe for
you here is a study that
John Bargh did roughly fifteen
years ago, that brings out the
relation between controlled
and automatic thought.
So Bargh brought subjects into
his laboratory, and had them
engage in what's called a
scrambled sentence task.
The scrambled sentence task is
a task where you're given a
list of words, say,
five words.
He, beautiful, doorway,
relevant, Thursday.
And you're asked to put four
of them into a sentence.
In so doing, you're forced
to engage with the
meanings of the words.
The only idea of the scrambled
sentence task is to get you
thinking about various words.
So subjects in this study were
presented either with a set of
words that were just a wide
range of words, or with a set
of words, a portion of which
had terms specifically
associated with the elderly.
Words like wrinkly, and
bingo, and Florida.
Those subjects who unscrambled
the sentences that had words
associated with the elderly
presumably had primed in their
minds the idea of old persons.
And then the dependent variable,
DV, which Bargh
measured, was how long it took
the people, when they left the
study, to walk to
the elevator.
The subject who had engaged in
the typical scrambled sentence
task walked quite quickly
to the elevator.
But those who had been given
words associated with the
elderly went very slow.
Indeed, subjects who were in
the ordinary condition took
just over seven seconds to get
to the elevator, whereas
subjects who had been primed
with words associated with the
elderly took more than
a second and a half
longer to get there.
Now, presumably this was not
because they were consciously
thinking, oh, I've got to
get to my bingo game.
It was because an image of
something had been evoked in
their minds unconsciously,
beneath the level of
awareness, and had ended up
affecting their behavior.
And in a series of studies that
Bargh went on to do over
the next few years, and which
he continues to do now, he
found this effect over
and over again.
So for example, some subjects
were primed with terms that
had to do with politeness,
others with terms that had to
do with rudeness, and the
dependent variable, the thing
which he was measuring, was
how likely they were to
interrupt the experimenter
when they needed to get
information from the
experimenter.
Those primed with words
associated with politeness
waited almost fifteen minutes,
whereas those primed with
words associated with rudeness
went up right away, and
interrupted the experimenter.
More recently, in the domain
of embodied cognition, he's
been looking at things like,
what happens if you hold a
warm or a cold coffee cup before
you evaluate a resume,
and subjects who have, in
the elevator, helped the
experimenter by ("could you just
hold my mug, please?")
Holding a warm mug, as opposed
to ("could you just hold my
mug, please") holding a cold
mug, were more likely to
evaluate the resume
positively.
That is, a sense of warmth in
one domain brings with it a
sense of warmth in the other.
So that's the fourth division.
OK.
So what I want to do in the last
ten minutes of lecture is
to talk about the
two texts that I
haven't discussed already.
First, Plato's division into
reason, spirit, and appetite,
and secondly, the material
on dual processing.
Though this next lecture is
explicitly about dual
processing, if we don't get
all the way through that
material, I'll begin next
lecture with it.
So in the somewhat salacious
material from Plato that I had
you read today--I hope you read
it: It's really great and
really fun.
So in it, Plato--here's a
wonderful depiction of it by a
philosopher named John Holbo
who lives in Singapore.
Plato describes the three
parts of the human soul.
The first is what he calls
reason, or logos; This is
represented here by
the chariots here.
The second, spirit, sometimes
translated
as honor, or thumos.
And the third, appetite,
or epithumos
Now Plato presents a number of
metaphors by which we can
understand this.
In the Republic, in a passage
which we're reading for early
next week, he describes reason
as a human being, spirit as a
lion, and appetite as a
multiheaded beast. And in the
passage that we read for today,
from the Phaedrus, he
describes reason as "a
charioteer," spirit as "a good
horse, noble in frame,
well-jointed, with a high neck
and regal bearing.
His coat is white and he is
controllable by word alone."
Appetite, by contrast, on the
Platonic picture, is "a great
crooked jumble of limbs with a
short bull neck, a pug nose,
dark skin, bloodshot white eyes,
companion to wild boasts
and indecency, shaggy around
the ears, deaf as a post,
barely yielding to the horsewhip
and the goad
combined."
And Plato goes on to describe
in the passage that we read
today a rather exciting event,
where a man of Athens has
fallen in love with a young
boy, and the brown horse
within him, his appetites, are
ready to engage in those
activities which fell into the
category of things that Freud
talked about in the id, and I
don't mean that he wanted to
eat lunch with the young boy.
Whereas spirit is attracted,
but recognizes the ways in
which there are social norms,
and the charioteer is involved
in trying to keep
them in line.
So Socrates writes of the
process by which the
charioteer tries to bring the
dark horse into line, as the
dark horse basically tries to
get the man to embrace his
young beloved.
So he says: "the promised time
arrives, the horses pretend to
have forgotten what they were
told by the charioteer.
It reminds them.
The horse struggles.
It neighs.
It pulls them forward.
It forces them to approach the
boy again with the same
proposition, and as soon as they
are near, it drops its
head, straightens its tail,
bites the bit, and pulls
towards the boy without
any shame at all."
The charioteer--that is reason,
self-regulation, the
superego, the prefrontal
cortex--is struck with the
same feelings as before, where
he feels like this is not
activity that he wants
to engage in.
"Only worse, and he's falling
back as he would from a
starting gate.
He violently yanks the bit back
out of the teeth of the
insolent horse, harder this
time, so that he bloodies its
foul-speaking tongue and jaws,
sets its legs and haunches
firmly on the ground, and
causes it to stop."
Now this idea that one of the
ways in which we learn to
control our passions is by
training ourselves as we would
train a wild animal through
the creation of negative
associations with certain sorts
of activities is, in
fact, a fundamental insight
about how human
self-regulation takes place.
And with respect to truly
forceful passions, sexual
appetites in particular, a kind
of self-regulation that
involves an equally forceful
antidote is crucial.
Plato's picture is that in the
well-ordered soul, reason, the
charioteer, does the ruling, and
that spirit and appetite
are, through a process of
self-regulation, tamed and trained.
So what the Republic, the book
from which we've been reading
excerpts, describes, is a
process by which the rational
part of ourselves can come to
be in control of our spirits
and our appetites.
Plato actually tells the story
by means of a controlling
metaphor, which is that he
compares the structure of the
human soul to the structure
of a city.
And he says that just as in
the human soul, there is
reason, there is spirit, and
there is appetite, so, too, in
a well-structured city, there
are guardians, those governed
by reason, auxiliaries, roughly
soldiers, those
governed by honor, and
a kind of worker, who
is governed by appetite.
And moving back and forth
between the individual and the
society, Plato goes on to
describe a series of processes
through which the will and
desires and impulses of, on
the one hand, the auxiliaries
and the workers, and, on the
other hand, spirit and appetite,
can be brought into
harmony with what
reason dictates.
And it will turn out, we'll find
out in three lectures,
that this kind of harmony is the
answer that he's going to
offer to Glaucon's question
about why it is intrinsically
valuable to act in
a moral way.
So that concludes the
presentation of Plato's
tripartite soul.
What we will do next lecture
is to talk about the
discussion of dual processing
accounts in the context of the
two pieces that we're reading
for next class.
The first, as you may know, or
may have seen, is Daniel
Kahneman's Nobel Prize
acceptance speech, and you
have your choice of either
listening to the speech or
reading a somewhat more detailed
article in which we
describes its content.
And the second is a piece that
I've written on a notion that
I call alief, which tries to
bring together some of the
ideas that we have today.
So I hope to see many of
you back on Thursday.